hey boys and girls i'm tim ferriss i
would like to tell you about hrv
training that stands for heart rate
variability training i
was not a participant
in hrv training i didn't use it myself
for a very long time it was recommended
initially
by josh waitzkin who's a friend of mine
he is very well known
as a world-class chess player he's also
a black belt
brazilian jiu jitsu under fina nine time
world champion marcelo garcia
and he's currently working on many other
crafts also happens to be a world
champion
in tai chi push hands so he understands
a thing or two about high performance
he also works with a lot of the best
performing investors in the finance
world
they all use hrv why so let me take a
step back we often think about
changing how we feel changing our
physiology by changing our content
so can we go to therapy and
talk ask questions be asked questions
such that
we change the stories in our minds so
that that changes how we respond to
things which changes how we feel
and voila we have increased well-being
now
that is not a bad approach but it is one
tool
another tool and another approach and
another paradigm
is to say maybe we can move in the
opposite direction so we change our
physiology and by changing our
physiology
we change how we feel and that changes
the content
all right this is actually really
important to grasp
so in other words you're working from
the body to the mind as opposed to the
mind to the body and i believe that both
can be really effective
athletes use hrv all the time the tools
that i have used
first are elite hrv i believe it's
called
it is effectively a pulse oximeter so
you clip it onto your finger
and i use that for calibrating the
morning resting
hrv then i use the aura ring which i
don't have on right now i actually use
it exclusively for sleep
o-u-r-a or a-ring which is
one of the better devices for tracking
sleep quality and hrv
and the woman i have worked with most
closely with respect to hrv is dr leah
lagos l-e-a-h-l-a-g-o-s
and she has a book on the subject so if
you search her name on amazon or
elsewhere you will find
this book and really more than anything
else because this is a set of tools
and this is one approach to working with
physiology to change how you feel to
change content
is to emphasize and really what i would
like to emphasize
is that when there's a problem very
often you'll be given a process that
moves from a to z
but sometimes if you're trying to get to
the middle somewhere you can also work
from z
to a and that is what hrv allows you
to do now the benefits that i've
experienced initially were
tremendous i saw it very quickly within
a week or so instead of it taking say
30 minutes to 90 minutes for me to fall
asleep i have a lot of
onset insomnia i was falling asleep
within
10 to 20 minutes of laying down after
doing
brief hrv training for 20 minutes
right before bed and i used an app i
believe it's called breath or breathe
there are many you can use
ultimately by using leah's book and
their other resources online
you will determine breathing sequences
that you can use to achieve a certain
degree of resonance
and we can get into the vagus nerve and
all sorts of things but there's certain
breathing patterns you can use
to change your cardiac response in my
case
there's a certain number of seconds of
inhale and
exhale you set those parameters in the
app you press go
you do it for 20 minutes and that is it
it's it's a very simple practice i was
doing it twice a day
and i encourage you guys to check it out
enjoy
you